Щоб проголосувати на президентських виборах у березні,
країнцям, що мешкають в Росії, доведеться їхати
в Грузію, Фінляндію, Казахстан.
Або приїхати для цього на батьківщину.
Адже Центральна виборча комісія ліквідувала усі виборчі дільниці
на території РФ і перенесла їх до інших країн.
Зробили це на прохання МЗС України.
Аргументація - Росія є країною-агресором щодо України
і проводити там демократичні вибори проблематично.
Окрім того, в МЗС упевнені:
Кремль намагатиметься сфальсифікувати вибори,
а українським громадянам може загрожувати небезпека.
У Росії, за останніми даними, мешкають більше 3 мільйонів українців.
Щоправда, на президентських виборах у 2014 році
до списків були внесені лише близько п’ятдесяти тисяч виборців,
які перебувають на постійному консульському обліку.
Але з них тоді проголосували лише трохи більше тисячі громадян.
І навіть на президентських виборах у 2010 році,
коли ще не було ані анексії Криму, ані війни на Донбасі,
в Росії на виборчі дільниці
прийшли лише понад три тисячі громадян України,
з яких 75% підтримали тоді Віктора Януковича.
им не менше, незалежно від кількості голосувальників
та їхніх політичних уподобань, право взяти участь у виборах
арантоване Конституцією, і обов'язок держави -
забезпечити можливість українським громадянам
цим правом скористатися, вважають експерти.
Рішення про ліквідацію дільниць у Росії може стати
ще одним козирем у руках Москви проти України на міжнародній арені:
мовляв, це рішення - недемократичне,
а Київ намагається не дати проголосувати прихильнам опозиційних сил.
У Росії було лише п’ять дільниць на території українських дипмісій,
і формувалися члени їхніх комісій виключно з представників цих дипмісій,
тому аргумент про ймовірні фальсифікації з боку російської влади
на дільницях під час голосування Кремлю легко буде спростувати,
зауважують експерти.
А у громадянській мережі "Опора",
яка вже понад десять років моніторить виборчий процес в Україні,
зауважують, що ЦВК загалом слід звернути увагу
на проблеми з волевиявленням українців за кордоном.
За даними експертів, мільйони українців у різних країнах світу
вже не вперше не можуть повноцінно взяти участь у виборах.
Усе - через недосконалу систему голосування громадян
на закордонних виборчих дільницях.
Найбільше українців за кордоном на попердніх виборах голосували в країнах ЄС -
Італії, Німеччині, Іспанії та Польщі.
Також експерти вказують на величезні проблеми
з волевиявленням тимчасових переселенців.
Таких нині на обліку - півтора мільйона громадян.
З них лише 44 відсотки мають намір
взяти участь на виборах цього року -
такі результати опитування Міжнародної організації з міграції.
На думку активістів з благодійної організації "Схід-SOS",
депутати та урядовці не опікуються виборчими правами переселенців
через те, що ті, попри свою чисельність,
не мають єдиних політичних уподобань.
Не зрозуміло, за кого проголосують переселенці,
тому ніхто не готовий робити на них ставку, зазначають активісти.